Air support send air support copy
that rogers inbound steve? Rogers!
Steve! Hey peggy now you owe me one.
hold on a second she's friends with that that
hydra stomper i think i'm friends with him too
reality is not a straight line every
passing moment is a chance for a new
offshoot a new variation in fact there are
more realities than you can possibly fathom
an infinite number of what is i'm jeffrey wright
and as the voice of the watcher in marvel's what
if i can see what few others can the totality
of the multiverse across all time and space
the stories you thought you knew are nothing
like you remember familiar are faces in
unfamiliar roles the captain women aren't soldiers
i would get ready agent carter no one expected
and foes who became friends
uh well i did not see that coming
Welcome back everyone this is going to be my new
marvel what if episode 1 video they just dropped
a whole bunch of new footage a couple scenes
from that first episode so we'll break it all
down there's a whole bunch of easter eggs i will
be doing videos for all the episodes they start
next week so be sure to subscribe to get all those
we're doing a giveaway for disney plus memberships
all you have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and just leave your favorite easter egg from all
this brand new footage i'll just start at the
beginning of this and work our way through shot
by shot talking about easter eggs as we go along
because there's a lot of different stuff that they
cover in this and as you probably detected when
they're talking about the multiverse the graphic
that they use they talk about different timelines
different variations like different variants
they use the same graphic as the loki series used
to depict different timelines just confirming that
this is building on all the craziness of that
loki finale i explained in my last big video
too that the producers said this is meant to
be canon all the episodes are canon to the mcu
i know there was a lot of question about
that when they first announced the series
they said that some of these characters will
eventually show up in the live-action marvel
movies and other disney plus series but this big
scene from episode one is obviously just a twist
on a scene from captain america the first avenger
movie and you have peggy carter as captain carter
or captain britain however you want to think
about her with bucky in the howling commandos
on one of their missions and they're meeting the
steve rogers version of iron man for the first
time who they're calling the hydra stomper just
because his howard stark built iron man suit is
so huge it's basically like a giant tank size
version of an iron man suit because the whole
idea that things had not been miniaturized till
present day like tony stark was the person that
miniaturized all those components for his iron
man armors and some of these shots are literally
mirrored shots from captain america the first
avenger some of this plot will be very different
though like there was no giant tentacle creature
in the first captain america movie they're under
heavy fire they're getting their asses handed
to them and then steve rogers iron man swoops in
and saves the day but the way they're playing it
they haven't completely revealed his identity like
it's still a mystery who this quote-unquote hydra
stomper is so howard stark basically builds him
the iron man suit and he goes on missions with it
kicking a bunch of butt but nobody knows who he is
it's a big twist on the original iron man origin
story if you read those original iron man comics
the story was originally that iron man was the
bodyguard of tony stark but obviously when the
first iron man movie came out they completely blew
that up they're like no we're not going to do that
plot he's just going to come right out and say it
oh i am iron man originally tony stark did use a
secret identity but that was during the 1960s when
they first introduced the character so this is
them just having a funny moment with him showing
up peggy obviously knows exactly who's inside the
armor but the other howling commanders are like
wait a minute who's this hydra stomper guy that
you know and buggy figures it out because he hears
peggy saying oh it's steve like oh wait a minute i
think i know this hydra stomper too because even
though it does take a dramatic left turn with
the creation of peggy carter as a super soldier
the idea is that everything up to the point of
him becoming captain america is pretty much the
same so he and bucky grew up being best friends
they joined the war effort in everything up to the
point of him climbing in the machine to literally
get injected with the super soldier serum is
pretty much exactly the same but as you can see
from the later trailer footage what it looks like
happens is that when he climbs in if you remember
during the first captain america movie if you
remember richard armitage's character basically
tried to sabotage their effort and blow everything
up kill everybody in the room it sounds like he's
slightly more successful they say that steve
rogers has an accident so then you see all these
flames behind everyone here peggy carter then
has to climb into the machine while everything's
on fire and they're just barely able to complete
the experiment before everything goes up in flames
then presumably after they figure out what they're
going to do with captain carter while that's
happening howard stark is also in the middle of
planning his hydra stomper version of the iron
man armor the c15 designation on it makes it sound
like this is the 15th version of this version of
the iron man armor that howard stark has tried
to create and if you couldn't tell it's pretty
much everybody from the movies coming back to do
the voices of their characters like sebastian stan
came back to do the voice of bucky in multiple
episodes because we see bucky in present day
during the marvel zombies episode there'll be a
lot of different versions of the avengers across
different realities different universes so
it's not like we're just seeing one version
of the avengers so then you have that other
trailer footage with jeffrey wright as uatau the
watcher narrating talking about how reality is in
a straight line there's many different variations
and like i said they very literally use the exact
same method of visualizing the timeline as the
sacred timeline the loki series the loki finale
like it starts with what looks like a version of
the sacred timeline then he says that reality
isn't a straight line there are many different
variations and you see alternate timelines start
to branch out and become fully alternate realities
and they show you different frames different
scenes from the previous trailers we've seen
before in the episodes but it's basically them
using the loki finale in the way they visualize
the timeline during that to tell you how this
multiverse what if series is going to play out so
all the different scenes that they show you here
are captain america's shield in the ice there's
a scene of doctor strange fighting the darker
version of himself from the big doctor strange
episode the collector there's a version of doctor
strange coming to the sanctum for the first time
also from that same doctor strange episode some
of these scenes that they use for these different
timelines are actually from the same episode
but you get the idea it's all meant to represent
different timelines branching out things going
in different directions different realities the
true version of the marvel cinematic multiverse
there's t'challa star-lord a version of captain
carter jumping on steve rogers hydrostomper and
taking off into battle young t'challa being picked
up by yondu in wakanda as a child iron man being
saved by killmonger during the events of the first
iron man movie iron man in the giant donut during
the events of iron man 2 zombie scarlet witch and
then separately zombie captain america from the
marvel zombies episode t'challa star-lord with
the ravagers then someone inside the quantum
realm zombie hunter spider-man then there's a
bunch more that are way too tiny to see branching
out but just more scenes from the earlier trailers
then you see geoffrey writes uatau the watcher
looking out over the scenes of these episodes
playing out like his silhouette watching the
events of the first iron man movie play out
but things play out differently and he's saved by
killmonger and if you didn't read those original
what if comics or you're not really familiar with
the watcher character typically he has a base on
the moon where he's watching everything from but
he has cosmic abilities far side so when you see
the silhouette of him looking watching everything
that's not literally what he looks like that's
just a visualization of him watching from the
moon but i don't know if they plan on doing the
watchers moon base during this series they might
just visualize it in a completely different way
this is t'challa star-lord's boots stepping
in the puddle this is a different version of
the scene from the first guardians of the galaxy
movie with him coming to get the power stone then
a version of korath coming to stop him like i said
chadwick boseman did the voice of his character he
was amazing they said that he was actually really
excited to do this project and he actually is in
four total episodes so it won't just be like
one episode of him we get a whole bunch of him
i love jeffrey wright's twist on that classic
quicksilver meme i did not see that coming then
they have the montage of a couple really quick
scenes but they're really wtf scenes so for
instance this version of iron man seems like black
widow killed him inside randy's donuts during the
events of iron man 2. like you see him lying
on the floor there with his coffee spilt like
she poisoned him or something like that or she
shot him then you see nick fury and these shield
agents carting her off like they're arresting her
but you notice that it's crossbones and the other
people from the winter soldier which are known
hydra agents so during this particular episode
where this is taking place this might be a version
of black widow who either never stopped working
for the red room and she just pretended to defect
to the united states so that she could infiltrate
shield where she herself is hydra and this is
a hydra orchestrated hit on iron man during the
events of iron man 2. this is a version of yellow
jacket from the events of the ant-man episode also
probably related to what's happening with this
character inside the quantum realm and speak of
the devil scott lang only he's working in a dairy
queen instead of a baskin robbins i wonder if this
is just meant to be some funny twist like dairy
queen always finds out instead of baskin robbins
in this version of reality so just a big reminder
that episodes start next week my full episode 1
video is going to post wednesday it'll be the
exact same schedule as my videos for the loki
series just a little while ago congratulations
justin bt you're the giveaway winner from my
last big marvel video and funny you say that the
producers actually did say that any one of these
plot points anything from any of the episodes
could eventually become a spin-off in live action
everyone click here for that other brand new
marvel what if trailer footage they just released
and everyone click here for my brand new venom let
there be carnage trailer in spider-man easter eggs
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and i'll see you guys in the next video!